la policía canadiense se lanzó en una
cacería humana el domingo desde las 5:40
de la tarde recibe una llamada de
urgencia seguida por otras todas hablan
de ataques con armas blancas en
diferentes lugares de la provincia de
Chihuahua
hemos localizado a 10 personas
fallecidas en 13 lugares de la comunidad
de James Smith creation y weldon
saskachiwang varias víctimas adicionales
han resultado heridas 15 de las cuales
en este momento han sido trasladadas a
varios hospitales
creemos que algunas de las víctimas han
sido objetivo de los sospechosos y otras
han sido atacadas al azar si bien el
motivo aún no está claro lo sospechosos
han sido identificados se trata de dos
hermanos de 30 y 31 años Damián y miles
sanderson la última vez que fueron
vistos Fue en un vehículo de color negro
en la ruta para Regina una ciudad a unos
320 kilómetros al sur de los ataques en
del Primer Ministro de Canadá Justin
trudo condenó la serie de apuñalamientos
los ataques ocurridos hoy en Chihuahua
son horribles y desgarradores mis
pensamientos van dirigidos a los que han
perdido una persona cercana y a los que
han sido heridos los residentes de One
se han visto obligados a permanecer en
sus casas por razones de seguridad y la
localidad de James Miss creation ha
declarado el estado de emergencia
[Música]